the space race not between national
superpowers but
two of the world's richest businessmen
astronaut zero zero one richard branson
as the virgin galactic founder i am
sorry urgent galactic's founder sir
richard branson is planning to launch
above the earth's surface this sunday
if he succeeds he'd achieve the feat
nine days ahead of amazon rival jeff
bezos the unity 22 mission will be
virgin galactic's first to carry a full
crew of two pilots
and four mission specialists in the
cabin including
astronaut zero zero one
and virgin galactic's founder otherwise
known as astronaut zero zero one so
richard branson joins me now alongside
sirisha bandler the company's vice
president
of government affairs and research
operations great to see you
both so the countdown is on richard how
is it looking and how are you feeling
um we're feeling great um right behind
us you'll see the
mothership and the spaceship has just
been
attached to the mothership and and
so uh we're on schedule for
a launch uh and yes by maybe two or
three hours
i think before the world cup on sundays
um
sirisha is one of the uh wonderful
team of people who work for virgin
galactic who's coming with us
uh her life dream has been to be
i've been dreaming of this since i was
little and well i'm still little but
uh since i was young and i didn't meet
the requirements to go
be a traditional astronaut via nasa and
when i saw the announcement
that richard is going to be making a
space line um
that to make space available for for all
i knew that was the way i was going to
be able to fulfill my dream
so what does it take what kind of
training have you
been through richard in order to prepare
to be an astronaut
well as i think you know because i think
you might have been there at a very
original launch
um 17 years of
making sure that i keep fit healthy and
uh do a lot of kiting a lot of surfing
um
you know weight training extreme biking
and
and then do things like the centrifuge
which um
tests your body and replicates the
flight
and and yeah so basically just feel very
fit very healthy
and um and and very very ready for it
yeah
you mentioned you mentioned richard the
the original launch we were showing some
pictures we've been in our archives
back in 2006 i think i came out to new
york when you were
launching the prototype the the mock-up
of spaceship two
it's been a long time in the planning
this
uh it's been a long long long time and i
had no idea when you came out in 2006
just
uh how tough um
building space lines are how tough
rocket science is um
but anyway we've had 800 engineers
working for
17 years um they now have ticked every
single box
um and now we're ready for ourselves to
go
and then uh not we're not so long off
from
uh sending and sending people who are
watching this program
uh i mean my my dream is that young
people who are watching this program
can get the same excitement from it uh
on sunday
as was when i watched the moon landing
all those years ago
and just to show young young kids that
one day they will go to space
um and that anything's possible and and
you know if
i've dreamt of building our own space
line
uh a spaceship that we could go to space
on um
and yeah it's taking a while but um
hopefully on sunday the dream will come
true sirisha we've just seen uh some
pictures of you
and the rest of the crew what will you
be doing on the mission what is its aim
yeah well yeah no no you're doing it um
so i'll be testing the researcher
capabilities
on onboard the spaceship so we'll be
taking future astronauts who want to
experience
the awe and view of earth from space but
we'll also be taking researchers
and educators that want to conduct
science develop new technologies
on board the spaceship so i'll be
testing that human tended
uh experience for science and technology
um i can hear from both of you the
excitement building up to this
but is there are there any nerves are
there any rituals that you'll be doing
before you fly
well i i'm excited and just
just so ready and i think that's really
due to our team
we have an excellent chief astronaut
trainer we've got excellent crew
richard um colin from the uk um
two excellent pilots um they just built
and instilled confidence in me for the
slight and my ability to do my job so
right now i'm not nervous i'm just
really excited and ready
and what about you richard um yeah no i
i'm exactly the same
you know we've we've it's taken a long
long time
to have uh our chief engineer say that
every box has been ticked
you know we now uh have a spaceship uh
that we're happy with that we've tested
and tested the rockets
um and we've tested and tested the
mothership uh we're sitting in this
beautiful spaceport i'm looking forward
to
showing it showing it off to you all on
on sunday morning i mean it's
absolutely stunning just emerges from
from the desert here in new mexico
and so we're ready and we're i haven't
let myself get excited for 17 years
and now i'm letting myself get very very
excited and richard you don't get to
where you are without a healthy
competitive
instinct how important is it for you to
beat jeff bezos
i know nobody will believe me it
honestly isn't important i mean what
what is important is that we can both
create
um very safe um
uh space lines uh that can offer
uh young people who are watching these
programs
um a chance to go to space one day
and it's gonna take us quite a long time
to be able to
build enough spaceships to bring the
price down so that
young people you know will be able to go
to space but that was the same with
ordinary airline travel you know back in
the 1920s
it was only the rich people that
traveled
but they then enabled more and more
space
sorry more and more airplanes to be
built which has enabled
more and more people to be able to fly
and and the same will happen i think
with this
uh richard branson seresha bandler thank
you both very much indeed the very best
of luck we will be watching
thank you thank you